just to i guess not mince any words do
you want to tell us what the story's
about and yeah this is a a whistleblower
current employee at pfizer
melissa is her name and she and she uh
took screenshots of some emails from
executives advisor including vanessa
gellman senior director worldwide
research and in these emails the
pharmaceutical executives say quote
one or more cell lines with an origin
that can be traced back to human fetal
tissue has been used in laboratory tests
associated with the vaccine program
now some of this is public knowledge in
that the fetal cells are used but what's
interesting about these emails is that
all these executives at pfizer are
saying to each other let's not tell
people that that's true
and i'm going to quote the email here
quote we want to avoid having the
information on fetal cells floating out
there we want to avoid
this is a direct quote the risk of
communicating this right now outweighs
any potential benefit we see
and they say to hide this information
public so
investigative reporting is always about
making public what people want to keep
secret so my question is why
are these pharmaceutical executives in
their emails trying so hard to keep this
information secret and this outraged the
whistleblower so much that this woman
went public yesterday night with project
veritas on the record she's currently
employed by pfizer probably the first
time anyone has ever done this sort of
exposed the pharmaceutical industry
everyone says i should be worried about
this
but i
this whistleblower has informed me that
a lot of people at pfizer agree with her
and we're looking forward to more pfizer
employees coming out now here's the
interesting thing we have this uh i
pulled this up earlier in the day on a
different segment children's hospital
philadelphia that says vaccine
ingredients fetal cells and all of these
there's a whole bunch of articles that
are like certified fact checks say no no
no there's no fetal cells in the
vaccines don't worry about right no the
issue is they use them in manufacturing
or the testing of the vaccine so you're
not getting injected with it but in
order to make them to do the tests they
are using them now there's a couple
really interesting things as it relates
to your story the first thing is this
website from the children's hospital of
philadelphia mentions that the jansen
vaccine the jnj vaccine does
use uh viruses grown in fetal cells but
that's the only one it doesn't mention
pfizer so i don't think we had any
confirmation that pfizer was actually
using fetal cells we do have states and
i'm reading from a count the state of
california says quote
pfizer does not require the use of any
fetal cells in order to manufacture
produce the vaccine so this would be a
direct contradiction what the executives
yep go ahead well in the manufacture of
this this this was in the lab tests
laboratory tests yes so that that's
that's that's what i'm saying i feel
like you know one of the things i
mentioned to people earlier in the day
was
we're going to end up seeing a
congressional hearing we're going to get
some republican going like what's this
project veritas report i hear where
you're using fetal cell tissues in the
production of this vaccine and they'll
say we do not use any fetal cells in any
capacity manufacturing this vaccine it
is fake news they're online conspiracies
oh we did do tests using them to get to
the point where we could make the
vaccine laboratory tests right so what
you're saying is they're going to sort
of do a non-sequitur and say well we
don't use it to put it in the vaccine
that goes in your body but two things
can be true they can use it in
laboratory tests and also not use it in
the in the product and they'll and
they'll twist it so right i imagine this
you'll get some a rand paul whatever
being like we have a report from veritas
that laboratory tests in the production
of the vaccine and they'll change the
subject exactly right they'll change
something and say we do not manufacture
the vaccine with fetal cells that's not
true and then when the republican
if any of the republicans actually do
question this will either miss the
manipulation or not have enough time to
follow up and that's the political game
they'll play so i do that's particularly
fascinating but i will add to on top of
all of that just from this article from
chop.edu when they mention why they use
fetal cells this is what that really got
me they said it's because fetal cells
can typically divide more times than any
other cells they say uh in fetal cells
it is around 50 divisions they can make
other cells can only can divide
substantially less because they're older
cells
so it sounds to me like it would just be
an inconvenience to use cells that
aren't from aborted fetal tissue but
they're making a cost-effective decision
that it's cheaper and more effective
right and and uh this is another quote
from the email here from vanessa gellman
senior director worldwide research these
are not low-level employees tim
sometimes we get criticized for going
after mid-level no these are these are
high-level people here of vanessa gilman
saying quote general members of the
public who may take this information and
use it in ways we may not want it out
there avoid raising this as possible
what's interesting about these pfizer
emails is they also talk about facebook
they say we don't want this information
on facebook
which is deeply ironic given all the
censorship occurring about our videos
are being taken off facebook so these
executives are are so concerned about
people knowing this information that the
cells are used in the development of the
vaccine
man it just makes me feel like um our
our these massive multinational
corporations elements from the
government big tech
they know the re that the masses the
populace opposes this stuff they know
they have reason to fear if people hear
about this they'll object to it
they know what they're doing violates
the morals and ethics of regular people
and so they're like just don't let them
know about it yep just hide it from them
and and uh but the good news the silver
lining in all this in this dystopian
reality is that uh i find that you know
when i met with you a year ago we talked
about this vision to manifest you know
hundreds of whistleblowers these days
they're all i mean i'm talking tens of
thousands of people have messaged me in
the last few weeks so it's all happening
it's happening um because there's no
place else for them to go and and it's
getting worse and worse that that
divergence between reality and what's
presented on cnn it's just that that's
getting wider of a gap seeing the people
chanting let's go brandon all over the
place
yeah i mean i know it's a funny thing
but
these are regular people at a jets game
at a football game
just take a look at what is the the
falchi documentary that's coming out on
disney right i mean and you see the
trailer for it on youtube and it's got i
don't know 7 000 thumbs up and it's got
75 000 disapproval thumbs down
like that's a really good moment for
people in america who are like yeah you
know what maybe we should be talking
about mandates versus you know
absolutely
the government not having this power
yeah i think we have to be careful we
talked about the other day about getting
wrapped up into like discussions about
exemptions because we should be just
saying no mandates period
because i think i think the
any argument that says there are some
mandates that are some okay some of the
times as long as we have exemptions
results in a social credit system
but you know
well in my opinion the vaccine passport
um is not going to lead to a social
credit score because it already is a
social credit score it's already the
score of compliance that people have to
jump through they know that there's
going to be a third one they know that
it's going to be a fourth one and
there's not even a conversation when
this is going to end usually with the
lockdown usually with a policy that's
very intrusive in our lives the
government comes out and says we're
going to end this after this many people
uh you know die from covet after these
many cases we don't have any of that we
don't have any conversation to when this
will end when this will stop and it's
not going to stop that's the new
afghanistan yeah that's the thing is
there's no mission there's never been a
mission over there that i mean what
we've been talking about with the afghan
papers for what 20 years right oh yeah
no mission we're still sending guys
outside the wire it's a never-ending
mission and this is the same thing it's
like there is no end in sight
ever i i think the the the the big issue
here is uh with with james's story
you've got a lot of people who have
filed for religious exemptions and
they've been denied now first and
foremost like i said we'll be careful i
want to make sure we're very clear we
should be saying outright no vaccine
mandates period regardless we should be
demanding papers it's between the person
and their doctor if you want to go and
seek medical help it's between your
doctor not us here on the internet or
your business or the government
now you have uh you know government
officials and businesses with no with no
regard for your private health matters
and on top of that
imagine you're in new york city where
they mandate this and you've got some
embarrassing medical condition and now
you've got to go around every business
exposing this embarrassing condition
that should be private matter for you to
live your life with dignity that's
another reason why i'm just like they're
demanding ideas at the door that being
said
this is i think a lawsuit winner for
people who have religion who want to
assert religious exemptions yeah yeah
and they there's no religious exemptions
at pfizer for that's what this insider
came forward regarding so i think it's a
game changer for society it's just we
live in this dystopian reality where
these facts are just not even accepted i
mean things have changed so quickly even
since i last saw you i mean
uh in in a just world this would be on
the front page of the new york times and
on 60 minutes these are executive emails
advisors yeah you know what i'm pretty
sure everyone else was pissed off
equally as much by the same thing when
you see the fake whistleblower from
facebook and not a single whistleblower
that vertos has come out with is is
going to be propped up on 60 minutes and
given this airtime right that was uh the
morgan common at facebook blew the
whistle on the vaccine hesitancy scores
and he responded to uh blumenthal from
connecticut saying there should be more
people inside tech but the whistleblower
inside facebook the supposed
whistleblower wanted more censorship
yeah
i mean not even that i mean look at
assange look at snowden i mean these
people are still in exiles assange is in
jail his accuser who lied about
the main witness that the government had
against him was caught lying he was just
arrested in iceland just moments ago and
assange is still in jail how does that
make sense it doesn't work yeah those
are the real whistleblowers and then
there's whistleblowers that work towards
the agenda and the narrative that of
course they keep and they prompt they
make prominent number one news articles
on cnn that they promote non-stop thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you